president zelinski was not
attempted any contact for a direct
dialogue except some messages in public
so there was no official request being
sent to the kremlin i think that it's
logical because
before the negotiation teams will have
some sort of some drafts or some points
that are ready to be discussed by the
leaders i think it's just too early uh
you know to uh to manage this process do
you feel the russians are taking these
delegations and the the ceasefire talks
seriously yeah now we we are certain
about this because we see that they are
arriving usually one day before we come
they are pushing actually us for the uh
humanitarian missions and ceasefires
because this brings too much damage to
the image of the russia
because they're bombing civilians and
it's obvious now to every every every
person in the world so i think that
their main
target for for the closest sessions is
to try to show that they are not so
cruel as they see being seen right now
by the whole world but do you think that
they're negotiating in good faith and
what is the point of these talks when
there clearly is no cease-fire the
fighting continues no yesterday we
actually agreed for the very important
point for uh for for the process and the
protocols how to do the humanitarian
corridors and how to evacuate people who
want to go away
especially also like it's including the
foreign students we have about five
thousand indian chinese students in
kharkiv and sumi and other places